Twitter has permanently banned my pillow CEO
Michael Mondelēz account after he continued
to repeat bogus claims about Donald Trump
winning the twenty twenty US presidential
election.
Michael and Dell has been really a fixture
of disinformation.
He first appeared more prominently early in
the coronavirus pandemic.
He was up alongside Trump at one of the white.
Press briefings talking about how Trump is
a gift from God and Trump talking about how
Mike Lyndell, instead of making some of his
pillows, is going to make some PPY, I never
heard again about whether Mike Lyndell actually
delivered the PPE, but that's at least what
they claimed back in what was it may be May
or something like that.
In any case, he became Mike Lyndell became
a major player in claiming that Trump was
about to win, that Trump actually won, that
they're going to get Biden out and Trump in
for a second term.
And now Twitter has decided to ban Mike Lyndell
over, quote, repeated violations of its civic
integrity policy, according to a Twitter spokesperson.
Now, because Mike Lyndell has been posting
so much of this stuff, it's not actually obvious
right now which of his exact posts triggered
this suspension.
In even better news, Lyndell is up against
a possible lawsuit from Dominion Voting Systems.
We told you yesterday Dominion Voting Systems
is suing Rudy Giuliani for one point three
billion dollars for his defense that they
claim defamatory claims about them.
Now, Michael Lindell also may be getting sued
for his claims that Dominion voting systems
were part of some big election fraud that
he claims exists, but for which there is no
evidence.
He also urged Trump, you might remember, to
declare martial law in Minnesota to obtain
its ballots and somehow overturn the election.
Here was Mike Lyndell.
Quick reminder, at a pro Trump rally.
This was January 5th, not January 6th, the
day of the insurrection.
It was January 5th.
Talking about how Trump will be president
from November 4th.
On every day I have spent looking into the
election fraud.
I've worked with Secretary Powell, General
Flynn, all the guys with these machines, these
experts.
And I can tell you, one hundred percent, Donald
Trump is going to be your president for four
more years.
I have I have never, ever, ever said anything
less than that one hundred percent and just
today there was so much this morning I was
on the phone with General Flynn and just even
more evidence came out.
These are going to be bonus evidence just
to put more people in prison.
Now, of course, no one is in prison.
Joe Biden has been sworn in and now Mike Lyndell
is under threat of lawsuit by Dominion voting
systems and suspended from Twitter.
So, you know, I got into a little bit of an
argument with people on Twitter.
I believe that the my pillow guy is dangerous,
but he's dangerous not because of who or what
he is.
He's made dangerous by an American society
and culture in which lots of people fall for
the stuff, he says.
So what I mean by that is this in a more normal
world, no one would pay more attention to
Mike Lyndell than they pay attention to the
rantings of that guy on the subway platform
who's screaming stuff about repenting or whatever
the case may be.
In a more normal world.
This guy wouldn't be alongside a president
on TV and having the platform that he has
because of American society and culture and
lack of education and media literacy.
Mike Lyndell ends up getting propped up by
Trump himself, by Kuhnen types and even by
some of right wing media.
So the the the danger of Mike Lyndell not
and doesn't come just from oh, it's someone
in a country of three hundred and thirty one
million saying crazy things.
We have plenty of those people.
The problem comes from the way in which our
society is susceptible to falling for con
men like Mike Lyndell, like Trump on another
level.
And that's where the danger comes from.
So when people say this is just one dude,
how can you say he's dangerous?
Well, he's dangerous as a result of combining
him.
It's sort of like you can have components
to a poison that by themselves aren't poisonous.
When they come together, it becomes a poisonous
brew.
That's what we're talking about with Mike
Lyndell, Mike Lyndell, plus a susceptible
population, plus those who are susceptible
that have the ability to give this guy a significant
platform.
That's where the danger comes from.